bonjour à tous on est au mwc à barcelone
gênes prendre en main la nouvelle
tablette de huawei la mediapad m5 trop
et je dois avouer que franchement elle a
plein de points positifs on va regarder
ça tout de suite
[Musique]
huawei est vraiment présent en force au
mwc ya plusieurs stands de huawei il ya
un très grand stand qui est juste de
l'autre côté je voulais faire un petit
tour rapide juste là là voilà ça c'est
un très grand stand de huawei sur lequel
vous allez retrouver bien évidemment
oui donc ce soit les nouvelles tablettes
soient les ordinateurs on a des vieux
produira des mots du produit pas vieux
mais déjà vu le huawei nova 2 on a toute
la gamme au nord qui est présente
on a pas mal de choses différentes
daurade un petit peu en même temps pour
essayer de vraiment de vous illustrer sa
on y parle de 5 g il ya vraiment pas mal
de choses super intéressantes et
notamment les nouvelles tablettes qui
ont été présentés il ya pas très
longtemps
la mediapad l5 et mediapad 25 pros nous
regarder la mediapad m5 pro parce que je
trouve que c'est une tablette qui veut
tout cas vraiment faire face à l'ipad
pro d'apple alors on n'a pas s'amuser à
les comparer pour un parcours on va pas
décortiquer ça tout de suite ce qui
intéresse en tout cas c'est de regarder
un petit peu le produit en lui-même voir
à qui il s'adresse
voir ce qu'on peut faire avec est-ce
qu'il en tout cas sur une première prise
en main est ce qu il me paraît
convaincant bien ou alors pas du tout
alors la première chose qu'on va faire
c'est regarder un petit peu ce qui est
dans le ventre vous avez un écran 10,8
pouces en deux cas un écran en forme à
2560 par 1600 pixels l'écran paraît
plutôt pas mal je trouve assez brillant
vous avez un processeur maison c'est le
kirin 960 qui est couplé à 4 gigas de
ram 64 giga de stockage il tourne sous
android 8.0 avec une surcouche maison
est mu 8.0 également point de vue caméra
vous avez à l'arrière une 13 mégapixels
à l'avant une 8 mégapixels
alors très clairement cette même
tablette pour aller faire des photos
plus pour photographier des documents
photographiés quelques souvenirs si vous
cherchez une faute aux tablettes je ne
pense pas que ce soit là dessus qu'il
faille aller nous annonce également un
pc mode for work dont vous pouvez la
passer en mode ordinateur pour aller
bosser
on trouve également un style et de haute
précision qu'ils appellent le 4096 level
hai precision style s rien que ça vous
retrouvez quatre haut parleurs qui vous
donne sur la fiche technique ce sont les
quads speaker's n
ap matt cardle channing débrouillez vous
avec ça l'idée si vous voulez c'est
d'avoir des hauts parleurs spatialisé
quatre haut parleurs pour avoir une
meilleure répartition sonore j'imagine
que dans certaines applications
ça doit être intéressant pour pouvoir
effectivement se rendre compte de la
spatialisation d'un point de vue
purement classique à regarder des films
pas particulièrement l'intérêt mais une
fois de plus on est sur un modèle
s'adresse aux professionnels ça faut pas
l'oublier
côté batterie vous avez vraiment une
bête de compet avec une batterie de 7500
milliampères heures vous allez donc
pouvoir faire pas mal de choses avant
d'aller la recharger avant de repasser
aux stands et ça je dois reconnaître que
c'est vraiment un excellent bon point
est ce que cette tablette de huawei la
toute nouvelle tablette la mediapad m
synchro est intéressante et séduisante
est ce qu'il faut aller dessus
c'est compliqué de se prononcer
effectivement sur une première prise en
main sur un salon ja trouve plutôt pas
mal d'un point de vue esthétique en tout
cas elle fait vraiment le job il rien
d'hyper novateur on va pas sauter au
plafond et se dire que c'est vraiment un
truc de fou entre révolutionnaires
moi j'ai un petit bémol néanmoins sur le
style et je les utiliser sur la
navigation pour aller naviguer pour
aller chercher des infos dans les menus
j'ai trouvé que ça répondait pas à
chaque fois et pas de façon super
pertinente
j'ai trouvé que c'était pas hyper précis
qui est voulu confirmer cette première
impression en utilisant sur une
application de dessin un peu plus
classique
j'ai griffonné 3 cru que ce que je suis
vraiment pas un dessinateur il fait mais
plutôt très mauvais là dedans même mon
fils me bats c'est dire si la 4e roman
ou peu importe c'est pas le sujet tout
ça pour vous dire que j'ai trouvé que ce
n'était pas extraordinaire
la précision n'a pas bluffer
je reste un petit peu dubitative là
dessus alors effectivement c'est des
choses a confirmé sur des tests
ultérieurs pouvoir se rendre compte si
en dehors du salon plus tranquillement
est ce que ça marche bien mais voilà moi
c'est un petit peu tout de suite
le point d'interrogation ou gérer dessus
l'utilisation du stylet la précision
j'ai pu comparer j'ai testé
effectivement des styles et sur des
produits similaires sur un ipad pro est
fondamentalement ça marche super bien là
je serai vraiment sur ma faim c'est un
produit qui a été annoncé il ya très
très peu de temps donc alors à laquelle
je fais la vidéo je vais pas vous donner
de date de sortie en france
ils m'ont dit qu'elles devraient arriver
normalement fin mars mais on ne sait pas
par quel pays et d'arrivée en premier je
n'ai donc pas tout de suite d'un faux
concrète à vous donner sur les dates en
france
néanmoins je vais rechercher si j'ai les
infos complémentaires je voulais mais
bien évidemment dans la description je
vais compléter au fur et à mesure vous
inquiétez pas prendre un petit peu ce
que je peux vous dire tout de suite sur
cette première prise en main de cette
nouvelle tablette de huawei la mediapad
m5 pro dites moi vous ce que vous pensez
de ce produit est ce que vous seriez
intéressé par une tablette de chez
huawei est-ce que vous avez des produits
de web
c'est vrai que en termes de smartphones
ils sont hyper connus sont très très
très puissant
là sur les tablettes c'est plutôt bien
j'ai pas à cracher sur la joute s'est
vraiment bien j'ai ce petit point
d'interrogation ce petit bémol par
rapport au style et ses documents avec
un peu il ya plein d'autres choses de
huawei qui sont super g w c'est donc
restez connectés je suis tout à l'heure
ils ont inscrit stand dans le hall 1 qui
est vraiment réservé aux professionnels
il faut des animations spéciales
on ne pouvait pas y aller il ya un
créneau horaire aujourd'hui même ces
derniers jours du salon
entre 10 heures et midi pour aller le
visiter il y avait une queue monstrueuse
et ils ont strictement interdit de
filmer et de prendre des photos
néanmoins on a pu faire un petit tour
avec une personne du staff qui nous a
vraiment présenté les nouveautés de
huawei là on parle de nouveautés en
termes de produits grand public mais en
terme de 5 g en termes de positionnement
par rapport au réseau par rapport au
cloud par rapport à toutes ces choses là
c'est super passionnant tous ces sujets
on va continuer d'en parler je vous
invite bien évidemment pour ça pour
suivre tout ça à rester connectés à vous
abonner parce que il ya effectivement
beaucoup d'infos sur des produits les
smartphones et tablettes de la robotique
mais caprins de sujets passionnants ils
sont forcément lié à ça parce que quand
vous voyez des smartphones et des
tablettes c'est la partie émergée de
l'iceberg
il ya tout le reste dessous c'est un
petit peu comment ça fonctionne avec les
opérateurs ya une vraie guerre là au
niveau de la 5g
il ya plein de choses super
intéressantes et tout ça on en reparle
très très prochainement donc comme d'hab
vous invite à mener c est joli pousse à
vous abonner à rester connectés parce
qu'on va parler toujours plus toujours
mieux de high tech et de trucs super
cool merci à vous d'abord donné cette
vidéo n'oubliez pas vous être les
meilleurs je vous embrasse et à très
bientôt
ciao